bonsoir à tous et à toutes
le prix nobel de physique 2014 a
récompensé trois chercheurs trois
chercheurs d'origine japonaise pour le
rôle fondamental dans la mise au point
de nouvelles sources de lumière les
diodes électro luminescentes bleu qu'on
appelle les led ces sources de lumière
sont efficaces et bonne pour
l'environnement
et alors ces sources de lumière vont
être comme je le mets ici les lumières
du 21e siècle
les led vont être l'éclairage du xxième
siècle comme la lampe d'edison a été
l'éclairage du 20e siècle
c'est une rupture technologique une
rupture technologique qui a à la base
une théorie la théorie quantique
en fait ces théories quantiques est née
au début du 20e siècle et a mené un
certain nombre d'applications importante
fondamentale
le transistor à la base de
l'électronique mais aussi un objet qui
au départ était très mystérieux le laser
laser devenu un instrument précieux pour
les médecins en chirurgie mais aussi
plus banalement le laser on le retrouve
à tous les comptoirs pour la lecture des
codes barres alors au départ pourtant la
théorie quantique n'a pas été acceptée
elle n'a pas été acceptée parce que elle
bousculer la vision que l'on avait de la
physique
en fait c'était une rupture les ruptures
sont rarement accepté facilement à cette
même époque au début du xxème il est une
rupture au niveau de l'art oui la
peinture abstraite
peinture abstraite aussi changer la
vision que l'on avait du monde de la
représentation
alors qu'à porter en fait la physique
quantique
qu'est ce qu'elle a proposé elle a
proposé de nouveaux objets ni particules
ni honte des objets complètement dingue
pour reprendre l'expression du grand
physicien richard feynman
elle a proposé une autre vision du monde
microscopique
elle a proposé d'entrer dans une terra
incognita que les physiciens ont vite
occupés est en fait cette évolution de
la science n'a été possible parce que la
science est libéré des dom
la science a acquis son autonomie cette
longue histoire de la science c'est
l'histoire de l'intelligence face à
l'obscurantisme d esprit critique face
aux dogues matiz c'est l'histoire de la
raison et du doute
face à l'incertitude c'est une longue et
belle histoire
on devrait la raconter à nos enfants
leur expliquer la persévérance des
savants leur expliquer que les avants
ont dû se battre face à ceux qui
n'acceptaient pas les conceptions qu'il
proposait parce que on pensait que ces
conceptions à les troubles et les
croyances et en fait oui les savants ont
dû se battre contre une conception du
savoir enfermé dans une conception
unique de la vérité alors qu' il faut
promouvoir au contraire à savoir ouvert
sur le monde
un savoir ouvert sur les civilisations
c'est ce que révèle dean que vous voyez
là premier ministre tunisien dans la
deuxième moitié du 19e siècle a voulu
introduire dans un nouveau système
d'enseignement qui a été fondamental
pour l'évolution des thunes
si cet enseignement appelé
l'enseignement syndicats oui que voulez
faire le dinh reloaded voulait que la
tunisie rattrape le retard scientifique
parce que la tunisie avait oublié
pendant plusieurs siècles la science
comme d'autres pays arabo musulmans
oui le monde arabo-musulman a oublié la
science de ses ancêtres
je vais vous raconter le dernier épisode
de l'astronomie arabes s'étaient
istanbul istanbul 577 un observatoire a
été construit magnifique avec des
instruments les plus performants de
l'époque comme d'ailleurs l'observatoire
qui a été conçu au nord par tycho brahé
grand physicien grand astronome en
disait pas physicien à l'époque
astronome danois est donc cet
observatoire de tycho brahé était
installé au palais durrani bord les deux
observatoires d'istanbul et de ce pays
du nord ont eu des destins complètement
opposées après l'apparition d'une comète
dans le ciel boréal pour tycho brahé ce
fut d observation fondamentale qui par
la suite ont mené au développement
extraordinaire de l'astronomie dans le
monde européen
je pense que tout le monde la connaît
mais à istanbul malheureusement ce fut
la fin d'une belle aventure scientifique
alors pourquoi parce qu en fait chacun
avait interprété sakho m ma istanbul sur
ordre du sultan
l'observatoire fut détruit en 480 parce
que le sultan n'avait pas accepté le
présage de l'astronome
alors aujourd'hui on en sait plus sur
les comètes vous
savait plus maintenant on donne même des
rendez vous depuis la terre la science
est aussi au coeur du développement
économique
c'est l'europe s'est construite s'est
développée économiquement grâce au
développement scientifique erding dont
je parlais tout à l'heure la bien
compris red dean qui disait qu'il
fallait prendre la science d'où qu'elles
viennent
oui il fallait prendre la source d'où
qu'elles viennent et il fallait que nos
enfants la découvre très tôt il fallait
éduquer nos enfants dans cette double
culture
bien sûr leur donner un enseignement
traditionnel à l'époque où dix neuvième
siècle c'était difficile de dire le
contraire mais leur donner aussi cet
enseignement des sciences modernes des
langues étrangères
oui c'est grâce à cette double culture
que la modernité est entré en tunisie
oui cette modernité qui est en moi que
je porte dont je suis fier oui cette
modernité mes parents me l'ont apprise
nous l'inculquer mon grand père
instituteur de français et d'arabe
mon père pharmacien biologiste regardez
cette photo
cette photo mon père est un de ses
élèves ses élèves de l'école
franco-arabe de sfax
c'était l'année scolaire 1921 1922 tous
habillage bas sauf institutrice et tous
épris des valeurs d'égalité et de
liberté
les valeurs de la révolution française
tous pour l'ouverture sur les autres
cultures
oui l'ouverture sur les autres cultures
c'est ce qui permet de connaître l'autre
c'est ce qui permet de respecter l'autre
c'est ce qui permet de partager cela
doit être au coeur du système éducatif
oui la mission de l'enseignant est riche
il est passeur de savoir il est passeur
deux cultures il est aussi passeur de
valeurs des valeurs à partager par tous
sur cette planète
l'égalité j'en parlais l'égalité pour
tous et l'égalité pour les femmes et les
hommes
oui l'égalité pour les femmes et les
alors en tant que tunisienne je voudrais
vous dire que pour moi qui suis donc
d'un pays de culture musulmane
je crois que les femmes en terre d'islam
n'ont pas à subir un statut
d'infériorité
oui et déjà ce principe d'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes tarder est
théologien tunisien l'affirmait en 1930
et son fameux ouvrage notre femme la
législation islamique et la société a
été traduit en français vous voyez ici
la couverture du livre et à la fin du
livre une figure qui peut vous étonner
on n'a pas le temps de la commenter mais
je vais vous lire le la petite légende
notre femme en train passe évanoui et un
présent prometteur un présent le présent
parlons-en nous sommes inquiets oui nous
sommes inquiets par la violence par les
actes de barbarie dans la région oui
nous sommes inquiets le 18 mars dernier
en tunisie mon pays
le musée du bardo a été attaqué il ya eu
des victimes
je le rends hommage mais le musée du
bardo je voudrais vous dire c'est le
musée de la méditerranée c'est la
musique ou toute l'histoire de la
tunisie présente la tunisie qui a été
berbère punique romaine byzantine
vandal puis musulmane et arabe
alors
que faire que faire face à cette
violence
oui il faut préserver nos enfants il
faut préserver nos enfants de ceux qui
les invite à camper dans le pré de
malédiction pour entretenir les suppôts
du démon et la séquence de la haine
destructrice
je reprends là l'expression de d'un
grand penseur tunisiens à de l'oms up
disparu depuis peu je lui rends hommage
oui cette violence comment réagir à
cette violence est bien tous ensemble
chacun à sa manière chacun
là où il est alors en tant
qu'enseignante et scientifique
je voudrais très vite vous parlez de 2,2
exemple l'un c'est l'histoire de ma
collègue saïda aloi biologiste et
didacticiel qui a compris que en fait
les élèves nos élèves de classes
terminales qui étudie la théorie de
l'évolution avait une compréhension
un peu qu'on peut on va dire composite
de la diversité du vivant il mélangeait
les référentiels scientifique et
théologiques et il a fait un travail
avec eux et les élèves ont compris ils
ont compris qu'il fallait se mettre dans
la peau du chercheur qu'il fallait
accepter les clés de la science les clés
du savoir
le questionnement et l'esprit critique
le deuxième exemple concerne la
communauté scientifique
cette communauté scientifique qui doit
se battre contre les obscurantistes qui
malheureusement sont en train d'investir
la toile
oui cette communauté scientifique
celle des académies des sciences a fait
une déclaration alors elle a regroupé
les académies des sciences de 68 pays
d'europe d'amérique latine des états
unis d'afrique d'asie et parmi ces pays
des pays arabo musulmans
la république islamique d'iran le
royaume du maroc la turquie la palestine
peut-être que j'en oublie mais en tout
cas ces déclarations que dit elle elle
montre qu'il est important d'enseigner
la théorie de l'évolution qui est
tellement attaqué sur les réseaux
sociaux sur internet et que
l'enseignement de cette théorie qui est
en fait accepté par la communauté
scientifique va apporter aux élèves une
connaissance importante puisque la
théorie de l'évolution est une des
grandes avancées de la connaissance et
cette déclaration appelle les
enseignants les décideurs les parents à
éduquer leurs enfants pour qu'ils
comprennent la science mais rappelle
aussi quelque chose d'intéressant c'est
que il y un certain nombre de questions
que l'on peut pas expliquer par la
science il faut alors adopter d'autres
approches philosophiques sociales
culturelles religieuses
ces approches ont des champs d'action
différent ils ont des champs d'action
différents et ils se doivent
un respect mutuel alors cette
déclaration est un magnifique appel un
magnifique appel d'une communauté
scientifique
voyez de cultures différentes de
cultures diverses
mais un appel pour que les jeunes
comprennent ce qu'est la science pour
que les jeunes comprennent que la source
est universel
et j'ajoute aussi parce que c'est ce qui
est sous-entendu dans cette déclaration
les droits de l'homme aussi
c'est universel et c'est cette
universalité pour laquelle je me bats
merci